-James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
Wow.
Very autumnal.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, ballot boxes, for
looking like regular mailboxes
that got buff during quarantine.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, pumpkin carving set,
for being the least used thing
in my utensil drawer,
right next to my bluetooth
meat thermometer.
[ Laughter ]
I promised I was going to
use that one.
Hmm.
♪♪
Thank you, Harley-Davidson,
making an electric bike
for being the most surprising
product release since
John Deer's line of
eco-friendly, organic eye cream.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, new Budlight
Peppermint Patty Hard Seltzer,
for being a good option for
people who are tired of
putting Listerine
in their soda stream.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, maybe I'll --
Don't knock it, all right?
♪♪
Thank you, quails,
for being pigeons that do
makeup tutorials on YouTube.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, axe murderers,
for being the only type
of murderer that needs
a specialization.
[ Laughter ]
Jake here is an axe murderer.
Yeah.
Kyle's more of a knife murderer.
[ Laughter ]
He's one of those gun murderers.
We are down to our last one.
-Aww.
-Sorry, folks, it just has to
happen, you know.
[ Laughter ]
[Southern accent ]
You know, what?
I'll get here
and I'll read my jokes.
And I'll just, I want to
give you the best
thank you notes I possibly can.
[ Laughter ]
And that's why,
I had added this last one.
Because we were only going to
do, was it nine?
[ Laughter ]
But no, for you, especially.
Because you're the best
audience ever.
You're the best crew ever.
And the best band ever.
One more thank you note!
Here we go. Here we go.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Drum roll stops ]
♪♪
Thank you,
full moon on Halloween,
for being definitely not
a bad omen
in the scariest year
of our lives.
There you have it, everyone.
Those are our thank you notes
right there.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh, guys, next week,
is election day,
but hundreds of thousands
of New Yorkers are already
voting early this week.
Now, the lines are long, some
people are waiting for hours.
And we wanted to thank voters
by doing something fun.
So, earlier today, our buddies
over at Williamsburg Pizza,
and we handed out slices
to people in line.
Also, everyone got a "Tonight
Show" "I Voted" sticker.
Because you got to get the
sticker, right?
yeah, but we thought we'd do one
better and give everyone
a "Tonight Show" "I'm Voting"
sticker, so they can wear that
while they wait
and then swap the stickers out.
Yeah, anyways,
let's check out how it went.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
-♪ Mesmerizing,
state of the art caffeine ♪
♪ Over your head
like Omni-verse screen ♪
♪ I'm not the average savage
that curse queens ♪
♪ I'm something
from his worst dreams ♪
♪ First we handling
first things ♪
♪ I'm subsurface unseen ♪
♪ Grat'll hold planet by purse
strings MC's are earthlings ♪
♪ Not built to hurt things ♪
♪ Speaking the words
of weaklings ♪
♪ Check it out ♪